okay so we are gonna be watching Green
Lantern yeah you're ready there you got
your Hamrick preparation there yeah I
haven't seen this I take about I've seen
bits and pieces but it was when he was
not the Green Lantern like this oh yes
so have you seen it before
no actually really no of her things
let's do this whiskey oh we got green
and we forgot that I love looking at
this movie like I'm looking through a
jar of urine I'm in a jar of urine
looking at this mythical mumbo jumbo
meant to sound importance wow that was
really unimpressive yeah that was like
nothing we're still going I feel like
this happens a lot lately where I see
these films I'm like no this has to be
like 1999
they see here one minute I'm already
completely disinterested ubi what are we
doing I mean what are we doing this
feels like an old cd-rom game he looks
like a Ratchet and Clank ruin what oh my
god Rob will make sure this is bad all
right like this is really bad
that was awful CG how can so much be
going on in the intro and I just don't
give a shit okay if I have to see one
more goddamn intro where somebody's late
for something
see very few people know this whole
movie was just a troll performance so
Ryan Reynolds could make a joke in
Deadpool I mean suddenly it's the most
amazing film ever isn't it he plays the
long game man so who directed this
Martin Campbell the guy who did the guy
who does or only than I did another
sequel though tzur oh yeah yeah it's
okay are we in hotshots cuz these are
the exact same effector hotshots what do
we know about this guy he's late well we
know about that alien he's late yeah I'm
not following this bomb assuming he was
going too far he was pushing the limits
he'll get a maverick maverick but he'll
be in trouble when he gets out however
it was damn fine flight brilliance big
joke we're doing that cause of the jagan
oh my god everything about it doesn't
look good it's not good effects it's not
good story now I have character I am
completely invested I really believe
that Ryan Reynolds hopped in a fake
plane the angry orange isn't as orange
as these fucking people
I just want to peel their faces and
squeeze their sweet sweet vitamin C
which juice out of them I can't believe
the guy who did go this well they all
look like golden eyes yeah oh he's a
rebel he parks on the sidewalk
I'll give this movie this I want cake it
accomplished that I wasn't thinking of
cake
there was a cake on screen now I'm
thinking of cake I didn't think of
anything else while watching this film
but now I'm thinking of cakes yeah
if cake 24/7 okay you know I think of
24/7 especially watching this maybe I
should have seen the psychiatrist years
ago if I'm gonna be a jet pilot and have
like debilitating PTSD flashbacks while
flying tell me the comics better I am
not kidding I need to be a long drunk to
get through heavy is like super like
curly sippy straws because I'm already
just stick to them answered the question
of when is bingo night I'm just gonna
put out there I just got back from a con
I was editing late last night have
another con this weekend we're doing two
reviews this week to make it so I don't
have that you know it's honest like is
it me or is this really really bad no
Isis dull boring stupid bad lit to look
I am the lod hideous hideous movie Medal
blue thing in every comic book movie I
like over saturated color but this is
like breaking me yeah this is fucking
ridiculous
yeah I kind of Lyle it's pretty Cracker
Jack ish I pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of Green Lantern
ism and to the shitty movie for which it
stands one nation under a bad Studios
decisions completely divisible with
diminishing returns for all my boy
present anything in there see I feel bad
for DC fans they just get the sloppy
seconds
I think they deserve better yeah been
replaced by an alien or something
[Laughter]
his father's pictures in that bar
honestly of my data getting blown up
wasn't very much an alien thing and he
was pointing his right how'd we get here
is super easy tried to be a superhero
where are they
I just see orange and orange and some
shadow is it like the matrix I have to
see past the numbers this is an orange
magic eye if you stare through the
borange long enough and cross your eyes
you see the image of a middle finger
coming out hits you no no you go back to
school no you go back to school like I
almost feel like I'm watching something
that came out a couple years after spawn
this is the sci-fi comic book version of
Eragon yeah there's so many fucking
cliches I mean there were ps3 games and
already looked like this or better
here's the thing if it looked fake I'm
really not that against it if it looked
nice and this is just so unappealing as
fuck he knows what's don't you that
makes you weak blah blah blah fucking
you're this a million times a bitch - I
was a great warrior salt his memory by
wearing his real what's he even he
hasn't said anything he's new to the
whole I mean why is it you're okay class
dismissed
I should write shitty screenplay hey oak
tell me this isn't the villain oh yeah
oh you gotta be shitting me
what
okay what is this no what is that don't
stop stop do over at the face of like a
grumpy Hillary Clinton especially now
keep drinking Ryan it's not gonna go
away mr. Reynolds action what am i
watching is this what you thought you
would see no see is that barely masked
man how's it gonna say let's see the
cauchy go all the way guitar solo una
okay a studio signed off on this I am
NOT falling in love with them no
director no no yeah I'm a died of
alcohol poisoning before this movie's
over this is not a specially long movie
you are its man I feel like we've been
watching this for days yeah that was
really boring and uneventful thank you I
mean in Superman it may have been goofy
is all fuck but like I'm flying around
the Statue of man yeah this we said and
talked we could have done that on this
fucking roof you know I just thought of
a super romantic scene he takes her up
there says I can do anything with the
mind show me he creates like a giant
bird or something or a plane or
something our magic carpet like a whole
new world or some day fly around and
they just sit up there what's he cooking
done he stopped the helicopter from
crashing that's all he's fucking done
and he just happened to be there really
yeah I'm going slower for genetic effect
I hope he doesn't break free he'll be
broken
how did we skip the scene a little I
mean how's this wife in the neighborhood
and I heard screams my transformation
into a bullfrog is now completed so
these were the cutscenes for the
videogame right I mean that's not a
finished product these are the
unrendered versions hey remember this
guy of course their connection is
timeless
their report the way to work off each
other ingenious I don't need to spin her
quite like that I just thought it added
a cool effect I like to show by the way
I literally just put a question mark
this part out if you can see for the
notes I just put a question mark oh just
for this whole gesture this scene I
don't even know what to say for the last
time okay you start that cliched line I
just wanted to know if you're good I
don't even go through all the way over
that yeah I know Superman just comes
around the car oh my god that must be
embarrassing for you let's go do
Superman for you know what I'm still
gonna walk out with a little bit of
credit now it's the fucking Empire
Strikes Back never tell me the odds
are you fucking serious you can be okay
so the Jets did nothing and he just
pretty much did a Bugs Bunny punch that
was the ark we did nothing and I'll
still look stupid I'm gonna look for
trouble let's go look for a better agent
turnout like I literally just wrote done
just done oh my god this movie this
sucked like this sucked I've seen better
I have you seen worse
oh yeah but not a whole lot this was at
least up to there so we have another
movie to watch after this - so my
thought would be it's easier it's a
shorter movie so hopefully no this is
this is the eye of the storm right now
because we got two in a row yeah
literally outside to us al it's we never
very rarely do two in a row like this
yeah what we have to do is cuz he is
gonna hurt marathoning it let's just do
it what are we watching kangaroo jack
fuck yeah alright we'll see ya later
you